Trump invited Artemis two into the Oval
Office. There was a bunch of uh media
there asking a lot of questions. Of
course, a lot of questions about the
war, but there were some interesting
things that got brought up. I want you
to listen to this because he's telling
us this is the year of disclosure. 2026
is the year of disclosure. We're already
in April, at the end of April. There's
not much time in this year. It It's
going to happen. I've been saying this
since last year that 2026 is going to be
the age of disclosure. They've been
putting it out with the documentaries,
with the Steven Spielberg movie. They're
telling us
we're going to tell you. Um check this
out. Listen what Trump said.
Mr. President, I have two questions for
you. First, on the topic of space, do
you have an update on the UFO files and
what might be when we're going to be
seeing them?
>> Well, I think we're going to be
releasing as much as we can
in the near future. For some reason, and
I guess it's just a reason that's been
in the minds of people for a long time,
and that is such They want to find out
about the UFOs.
And anything having to do with UFO or
related material that we're going to be
releasing a lot of things from that we
have. And I think some of it's going to
be very interesting to people. I've I've
interviewed people my first term
primarily, but I interviewed some
pilots, uh very solid people, and they
said they saw things that you wouldn't
believe. So, you're going to be reading
about it. Yes.
>> Sir, you
So, there he is. He's saying, "You're
going to be reading about it. We're
going to know about UFOs this year."
This is crazy because this is Bible
prophecy. If this is your first time
coming to this channel, if you've never
heard of this stuff before, I'm going to
show you how this ties into Bible
prophecy, um why this is a a deception
on a worldwide scale, and why we really
shouldn't be getting like kind of
excited over this. This thing tricked me
up my whole life. I was intrigued by the
paranormal since the second grade when I
went to elementary school and was
checking out books on ghosts and aliens
in the public school library. It was
books that were intriguing me about
UFOs, aliens. I became obsessed. My
favorite movies were Fire in the Sky and
Communion, uh anything that was made it
seem more realistic. I collected
figures, all that stuff. And it wasn't
until December 2011 that God knocked the
blinders off my eyes and showed me that
these are not just visitors from a far
distant galaxy. When you really look
into this topic, you will see that
abductees, people who have been
abducted,
are taken right out of the ceiling,
right through a closed window, that
these beings walk through walls and grab
people and try to pull them through the
wall. They defy physics on every level.
Their ships don't make sounds. They can
smash into the water without making a
splash. They can make 90° angle turns at
over 1,000 mph. They appear and
disappear off radar. They appear when
somebody's meditating in a field who
just wants to see this thing. You can
manifest these things. You can summon
these things, and people can channel
aliens and allow aliens to speak through
them. Guess what? That's not physical.
That's not little green men visiting
from uh millions of light-years away
from some other planet.
Everything about these creatures are
spiritual in nature. And so, we are
about to have full disclosure of demonic
entities in our realm, and this is
exactly what esoteric people like Alice
Bailey and uh
Helena Blavatsky were saying back in
their day. In the 1800s, they were
writing this. Actually, they wrote in
2025 would be the age of the the
externalization of the hierarchy. And
Trump's been saying we're in the golden
age, the age of Aquarius. This is all
been predicted in the esoteric realm.
Satan has a plan, and he is coming out
very soon, and that should be very
shocking for many people. Uh this is
just the different articles that are out
right now. Look, this just came out 5
hours ago, 7 hours ago. space.com, Trump
invited the Artemis two moon astronauts
to the Oval Office. Here's what
happened. So, you know, a lot of people
were kind of getting triggered. Why are
you talking about Artemis so much?
Because I put out five videos debunking
Artemis two's uh moon mission, how there
were all kinds of inconsistencies. Like,
when you really dig into the topic, you
look at the moon landings, you look at
ISS and all this stuff, you're going to
see inconsistencies, how hair sometimes
is stiff, sometimes hair is flowing
around. You see green screen glitches,
bubbles in space. You see harness wires.
All these things are proving that this
organization, a government organization,
I don't People don't think that NASA is
run by the government. It's nasa.gov.
They're literally shaking hands with
Trump in the Oval Office. They work hand
in hand. So, if you don't trust the
government, you don't trust Trump, then
why would you trust NASA whose acronym
just happens to be the Hebrew word for
to lie, to deceive, to beguile, to
delude, to lead astray. This is not
accident. This is not coincidence. There
is a reason. There is a purpose that
this  moon mission happened right
now because it is priming the minds that
space is real, that space exploration is
real. Look, if God destroyed a tower
that was being built called the Tower of
Babel,
do you really think that rockets are
flying out of our atmosphere and going
into outer space? It goes completely
contrary to what God's word says.
There's a firmament over us. When you
read Genesis, you will see that during
creation, God created waters. There was
nothing but waters, and then he placed a
firmament, a strong dome-like structure.
When you look up the Hebrew word, it's a
It's a a structure that was beaten out
with a hammer. It's a strong sky
stretched out like a tent that separates
the waters below from the waters above.
Do we believe God's word or do we not?
Do we think that Genesis is some kind of
metaphorical poetry, or is it really six
literal days and not six billion years?
If we take God's word literally about
creation, there's nothing above our
heads except a strong firmament and
water.
And that's why stars look like
flickering lights underwater because
God's word is true. Let God be true and
every man a liar. Jesus said in the last
days before he comes, "Let no man
deceive you by any means."
And yet, when I talk about the
deception,
people attack me and say, "Why are you
talking about this? This is dividing.
This isn't This isn't the gospel." But,
that's what Jesus said. Let no man
deceive you that there's going to be a
lot of deception in the last days
because Satan is going to deceive the
entire world. How do you think that
Satan is going to deceive the whole
world? He's doing so right now with a
whole space program.
This is an interesting article. This is
on New York Post. Just from last month.
It says, "Former Air Force missile
officer claims UFOs disabled nuclear
arsenal at Montana base during the Cold
War." So, this guy is 85 years old, a
retired US Air Force
launch officer claims UFOs disabled
multiple nuclear missiles dur- when they
appeared around the Montana base where
he was stationed decades ago. Robert
Salas claims a mysterious force
paralyzed the military's ability to
control 10 Minuteman
one intercontinental ballistic missiles
equipped with nuclear warheads at
Malmstrom Air Force Base in 1967.
The 85-year-old veteran said on the
Danny Jones podcast on Saturday.
Salas said guards insisted the crafts
weren't Soviet airplanes, pointing to
bizarre lights as they zipped through
the sky. Uh he initially brushed it off
brushed off the report thinking it was a
prank, but 5 minutes later, the guard
called back screaming into the phone.
"He's yelling. He's babbling. He's
frightened," Salas recalled. After
calming down, the guard told Salas his
men had their weapons pointed at the
craft hovering above the base's front
gate emitting a pulsating reddish light.
The panicked guard asked what to do
next, and he told him, "Do whatever you
have to do." The guard then said one of
his men had just got injured before
hanging up. All of the sudden, a loud
horn sounded at the controls signaling
that something was wrong with the
missiles. We looked at the board, and
sure enough, one of them went from green
to red. "No ability to launch," Salas
said. Then, very quickly thereafter,
bing bing bing bing, all 10 of them went
down.
They all went red. They jumped up and
ran through their checklist and realized
two launch facilities miles away were
showing that someone or something may
have breached the fenced missile area.
When they were about a mile away, they
saw the lights hovering above the launch
areas.
"They were scared to death," he said.
"They didn't want to go any further.
They were so frightened of these
things." He also learned guards
claimed to have seen the craft in the
area in the days before the encounter.
Craft that could reverse direction, snap
into sharp 90 90° turns,
and fly in total silence. Here we go
again with defying all physics. A
Boeing-led investigation could not
determine what the shutdown of the
warheads added that the system were the
systems were designed to prevent
jamming. They had no idea how the signal
could have been injected into
each of the missiles, he said.
The cabling system that we had was
triply [sighs]
triply shielded against electromagnetic
interference and from the outside from
the outside. Sala said he's convinced
that intelligence, non-human
civilizations, visited Earth to prevent
nuclear war. All right, this is the type
of stuff that's coming out right now.
Like, military people are saying UFOs
dis- disabled nuclear warheads. All the
time now we're hearing these US
congressional hearings with military
personnel saying we actually have
non-human biologics. We talk to
non-human intelligences. We communicate
with non-human human intelligences, and
we don't know what they are. They could
be interdimensional beings. That's what
they're telling us.
According to a formerly classified
document, originally made public in
2000, but recently resurfacing, a
bizarre and deadly encounter allegedly
unfolded somewhere in the Soviet Union
around 1989 or 1990.
The document, believed to be based on a
250-page KGB file obtained after the US
after the USSR's collapse,
outlines a chain of events that reads
more like a sci-fi movie script or a
novel than a military report.
It all started with 25 Soviet troops on
a routine training mission near a
military base near present-day Ukraine
or Siberia.
And that's when the soldiers reportedly
spotted a quiet saucer-shaped craft
hovering at low altitude. One of them
fired a surface-to-surface missile
directly striking the mysterious object
and bringing it plummeting to the
ground.
But what followed was anything but
ordinary.
Five short humanoid creatures reportedly
exited the craft. You heard that right.
According to the CIA document, they had
oversized heads, large black eyes, moved
with unsettling speed,
and later merged into a single
spherical-shaped glowing object. And
then
the unimaginable happened.
The object unleashed a blinding burst of
light, and within seconds 23 soldiers
were turned to stone, literally stone.
Two troops managed to survive only
because they were standing in the shadow
of a nearby structure.
According to the memo, the KGB wasted no
time. They allegedly collected the
bodies and the alien wreckage and
transported everything to a top-secret
facility outside Moscow.
As for the weapon that caused this, it
was described as something far beyond
what modern science could possibly
understand, let alone replicate.
Fast forward to the Trump
administration.
During his 2024 campaign, in fact, he
dismissed the idea of aliens outright.
But once elected, he signed an executive
order mandating the release of all
federal files related to
extraterrestrial activity. Trump said
Americans deserved to know the truth and
deserved to know if a decades-long
cover-up had actually taken place.
The memo at the heart of all this,
it's been circulating online for over a
year now,
and igniting a heated debate.
Was this an actual alien attack or just
a brilliant piece of Cold War propaganda
designed to scare the West?
I have a better question. Could this
have been literally demons?
Like, when you're reading the report,
you're talking about some kind of
creature that came out. And And why do
we believe this is alien? Why do any of
us believe that some kind of monstrous
creature is an alien? Is a visitor from
a far distant galaxy? Because we've been
programmed through sci-fi novels, radio
shows that evolved to movies like Men in
Black and all this stuff. Over the
years, we've been programmed to believe
that when you see an orb flying in the
sky, it's actually it's it's actually a
metal craft with nuts and bolts and some
kind of alien flying it from Mars.
That's
That's the only reason that our minds go
to that is because of the propaganda
that we've been fed our entire lives.
If we were 2,000 years ago and we saw an
orange flying ball go through the sky,
we wouldn't be thinking, "Hmm, I bet
that's an alien from another planet way
out there in outer space flying a
metallic ship through the air." We would
not think that because we were not
programmed back then.
This is We have been primed to believe
what Satan is doing right now. He's
setting the stage for his grand final
deception that's going to deceive the
entire world. That's how the dragon's
going to deceive the entire world.
Because how do you deceive Christians,
Muslims, Buddhists, atheists?
You don't do it in a spiritual nature.
You do it in a scientific nature. It can
be explained because atheists will
always say, "Well,
I'll believe it when I see it." Or if If
God would just show himself to me, I'd
believe it. Well, guess what? Satan is
about to appear as a cosmic
savior who's going to be doing lying
signs and wonders including miracles,
healing, bringing fire down from heaven.
And guess what? Everyone with just
rational, logical thinking is going to
say, "This has to be a good savior.
This has to be a benevolent being
because they came at a time of chaos
when there's wars." And what I'm getting
at is this this 85-year-old guy is
saying that UFOs were disarming nukes.
We just so happen to be going to war
right now.
We just so happen to be sending people
to space propagating this whole
deception that you can actually travel
outside of our world and there's some
ever-expanding vacuum that we can just
travel through and and see the cosmos.
When it it's
None of that is biblical.
And when you really get into it, none of
it seems scientific. It defies science
on so many levels, and I know that's
going to be triggering to people, but
look, if you put a
a bottle rocket inside of a vacuum
chamber,
it doesn't move. It doesn't have
anything to push off of.
And so this think that you can travel
through space and all this stuff. It
It's all setting the stage for the grand
deception, the grand illusion
that's coming that the Bible says is
going to be sent to those who do not
love the truth.
Revelation 16:13 says,
"And I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs."
Think about what these alien creatures
look like. Look at this picture right
here. Three unclean spirits like frogs,
"for they are the spirits of devils."
What are they doing? Working miracles,
"which go forth unto the kings of the
earth and of the whole world to gather
them to the battle of the great day of
God Almighty."
We know that Jesus is coming soon.
And these miracle-working
frog devils are going forth to the kings
of the earth, and just so happens that
we have US congressional hearings all
the times with the kings of the earth
gathered saying, "Yeah, we talk to
non-human intelligences. We think
they're interdimensional." This is
happening. We're living in Revelation 16
right now.
The dragon is about to deceive the
entire world by means of those miracles,
it says.
Then Trump commented about this little
thing.
I like space, you know, I started Space
Force, as you very well know. It's been
very very important, and they tried to
kill it. And actually the military would
not let the Biden administration kill
it. They wanted to kill it, and it's
turned out It's going to turn out to be
one of our most important things. I
think it'll turn
Space Force. Space Force is going to
turn out to be one of our most important
things. Why do you think he said that?
Why do you think defending Earth from
threats from space is going to be the
most important thing?
He knows. He's priming us
to be prepared. He's
He's priming us
to accept that there's a threat coming
to Earth from outer space that we need
to be defending ourselves against. Guess
what? There is a threat coming. It's
Jesus Christ. And if you're not on his
side, you'll be destroyed by the
brightness of his coming. And Satan
wants to go to war with Christ. Trump
unrolled Space Force, and when you look
up Space Force it didn't die out. It's
still going on two days ago. Donald
Trump speaks with service members from
across all military branches including
Guardians from the 18th Space Defense
Squadron. This sounds like a sci-fi
movie.
Guardians from the 18th Space Defense
Squadron.
I don't know. You just look at this
stuff and and you see
raises $650 million
to support space
interceptors, Trump's golden dome. What
is Trump's golden dome about? We did a
video on this
a year ago, but the golden dome is
a force field over America that's going
to protect us from missiles and other
outside threats. What are those other
outside threats?
Interesting, right?
When you know the truth about where we
live. When you know what the Bible says
about God's creation,
nothing's coming through here. There's a
firmament. Nothing's coming through the
firmament to destroy Earth.
Only Christ is coming.
In Ephesians 6:12 says, "For we wrestle
not against flesh and blood but against
principalities, against powers, against
the rulers of the darkness of this
world, against spiritual wickedness in
high places." That doesn't mean high
like in rank. When you look at other
translations, it actually says in the
heavenly places.
There's evil spirits flying around in
the heavenly places. We're not battling
against flesh and blood.
These beings are coming to unite
humanity in a battle against the second
coming of Christ and it's coming so
soon.
Guys, I hope you are hearing this. I
hope this is making sense. I hope this
is eye-opening and edifying. Please give
this video a thumbs up. It really helps
get this video out into the algorithm.
We are living in the last days. Everyone
needs to know what is coming and we all
need to be ready. The Bible says be
ready, not get ready. The church is
asleep. We're the 10 sleeping virgins,
but half of those virgins are going to
wake up and have enough oil to get to
the the wedding. The other half are not.
Are you going to be in the half who wake
up and have the oil?
I want to be ready. I want to be ready
when Christ returns and I believe he's
coming very soon. The signs are crazy.
We're living in Revelation and I hope
that that is obvious to you guys. I hope
you can see it. Please subscribe, click
the notification bell, share this video
with all your family and friends. If you
would like to support this ministry, you
can do so by going to candidtruth.org.
We got Cash App, Venmo, Zelle, PayPal.
We are 100% donation based. We cannot do
this ministry without you. We walked
away from both of our jobs in
just under two years ago now and thanks
to faithful donors like you guys, we've
been able to make it, but it's a
struggle. And so we need your support
and if you guys like cool merchandise,
we have shirts and mugs and shower
curtains, all kinds of stuff on our
website on the merch section and we get
about $5 per sale on everything that
sells on there. We love you guys. We
thank you so much. We cannot do this
without you. If you guys have been
supporting us, we see you. We love you.
We thank you and we will see you next
time on Candid Truth.